[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bella vita b
[Applaudissements]
fais moi le malao mafieux cuma tu passes
combien toi je pèse 83 kg 1 m 83 kg
septembre est assez lourd légers ou
lourds légers
il perd 2 kg les passants mais leurs
passes en mi-lourd toit rabaissé ouest
et passe en mi-lourds qui loba castaldi
tue parce qu'on vient qu'après un 5-4-1
6,2 à toi t'en journée c'est pas moi je
le dis tout le temps bravo pour
l'associer à la téloche y en a partout
dabs des sosies les enfants de stars on
n'a que ça aujourd'hui bien redémarrer
que les 24 antennes et ou s'il fallait
pas aller à la télé aujourd'hui mais
très vite on jack taunton ses vaches et
qui sont clean air belge max et vénus
faudra dire à nax que quand on se fait
mal sur un plateau télé s'est bien gardé
son petit jardin secret et faut pas non
plus tout partagé laquelle se plonger
sur pense qu'à pendant l'émission drones
challenge à les duos il devait piloter
un drone les yeux bandés le plus dur à
gérer c'est pas le pilotage c'est les
sauts de joie à la fin en gardant le
masque sur les yeux
c'est une estrade c'est une espèce ne
sera jamais retrouvé non ça y est ils
ont des soucis bien particulier quand
ils font de l'alpinisme 1 auquel toi tu
penses pas à direct bien du mal
accueilli la prothèse qui va éclater
attention la thérapie note on a croisé
de bol d'or qui s'est fait un petit
carré plongeant à la chantal goya d'un
bol d'or et avant de venir m'en a envoyé
une vidéo qui a fait le tour du web des
images de matthieu delormeau et gilles
verdez à la salle alors battu et donne
tout ça se passe bien mais pour gilles
ça s'est moins bien passé je cachais ici
mais c'est le nouveau nom de franck
dubosc
elle va bien charlie winston ce doux
qu'avec le temps c'est pas un look
sécher les cheveux pour y suivre ta je
travaille sur un biopic de gym vergès
[Rires]
chaque fois que je reviens avec les
cégépiens je suis contre tout je gueule
devant matin ça va faire une belle
histoire ici c'est terrible c'est cette
horrible le regarder quand on offre
viserait non j'ai dû beaucoup plus tard
il est plus beau et de plus en plus
d'amasser les cheveux qui peut selon
pour un film a très bien fait d'accord
c'est pour en remplacer quoi comme film
all inclusive le prochain film ça sent
bon c'est aussi la somme reçue à mettre
son talent la taille et la tht est parti
pour moi j'ai mon image préférée de
l'année je prêt à vous lire de l'année
j'adore franchement elle est folle c'est
dans la version sri-lankaise
d'incroyable talent puisque c'est dans
tous les pays au sri lanka aussi je vous
ne vous montrez pas une blague c'est
vraiment un gars qu'est venu concourir
dans la version sri lankaise c'est le
roi du kung fu ou qui la font il faut
qu'ils pètent des briques le gars et
voilà
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ses excuses à ses trois lentilles au
moment où on va on mettait son hi hi hi
hi dynamo 5 août et moi d'appel de la
haye a toute ma famille c'est une telle
hausse
je lui ai dit à mon sac ou encore la
semaine dernière arrête faire ôter
connerie et que les briques light élira
mais on peut pas avoir orienté la tête
du cdh rattrape mais il va bien on l'a
eu au téléphone et au téléphone
non mais non avril à il va bien la
mission continue à jouer pas en forme
mais fluide et aquaboulevard s'éclater
ce week-end y avait du sport un beau
coup de folie et mokhtar qui a été sacré
champion d'île de france de rugby vous
le saviez et nous alors et je dois dire
alors il parce qu'il me regarde tous
avec mon équipe de tennis
on monte en division supérieure bravo
vianney bâbord toute l'équipe voilà le
club de sophia antipolis voilà on a
gagné ce week-end donc bravo voilà près
de nice et mes études abb n'a pas duré
assez longtemps at on aussi le chan reec
les gars et gaffe à toi tu arrives pas
tu meurs du ya et il y avait un marathon
de paris madame la maire de paris anne
hidalgo a tiré comme d'habitude pour un
marathon ça se fait comme ça dans toutes
les villes celles qui a tiré le coup
d'envoi avec un pistolet et tu sens
qu'il ya le
à côté quelques est pas hyper seringue
fondue c'est celui de philippe deiss
france télé envoyé le meilleur
journaliste sportif du groupe pour
commenter la course patrick montel qui
encore une fois des creux voici le
pronom de patoche et j'adore parce que
je suis fan de ça la question que je me
pose c'est celle parce qu'on voit
léonida mosop plat la lièvre fait bien
son travail parce qu'elle peut aller où
il vient de s'arrêter elle vient de
s'arrêter au nom du tourisme
actuellement avec ses potes au micro qui
voit les choux dix huit ans après tout
le monde descend bas laisse un peu tard
non mais chapeau quand on a autant le
monde d'une famille qui participent à la
con chez sa fille zohra tarifs la nuit
quand même j'espère que toute la maison
est surveillée chute l'image du minesup
liberté regard des gains six pistes y
croise une manif trop macro et ils sont
tellement en marche qui le percute le
gars avant la vie le président il a
perdu une voile aujourd'hui nous avons à
celui d'aller à la rencontre des hors
séries a directement aller les
interroger sur caleçons lorsque leo
rautins priorité à droite à en [ __ ] on
veut pas voir shuma donc il essaie de se
rappeler aux jeunes et d autres
priorités
[ __ ]
on l'a tout de suite dans notre casse et
aux galères mathurine rappelé eric
massonneau sur la vie de ma mère
nicolas picard battue bat nicolas picard
eric massot non l'amour la huche
regardant le cas s'il s'appelait
commente offrant les bluebell ville
boubers ces canaux non le pauvre simon
temps là les auteurs du hors la loi
je vous l'avais dit il s'appelait
comment à la morinie ton mari mais rien
compris la question bat chute ça va
sinon non pas parce qu il aurait le même
genre de réaction ah ouais c'est du vélo
ils pédalent beaucoup en tout cas ce que
vous tenir
c'est une amie au fait que c'était
quelqu'un qui passe comme ça dans
l'édition mais qui reste pas et non mais
beaucoup merci j'ai maté du rugby ça sur
canal + sport - dieu à l'homme en qui on
a regardé le match d'agen ils ont battu
oyonnax 36 à 21 ans agen j'ai kiffé les
joueurs d'agen le capitaine déjà antoine
erbani caf un discours il m'a un
plaquage à ses potes l'air de rien sur
leur niveau en français et dans chaînes
[Musique]
ont fêté leur victoire regard des
libéraux de l'équipe
il met sa main pendant l'interview de
son pote de chemisage la pieuvre j'adore
cette blague est déposée par cyril
hanouna et quand on a trouvé la tête du
joueur qu après ça on a mieux compris
c'est bab al shamal thomas on va le voir
dans le vestiaire regarder mais ces
rituels actuelle c'est ouf c'est mon
frère en garde mais je le kiffe
non mais là il rassemble away est tony
touré fait quoi concevoir style pas fait
de boxe tu aurais tu étais bon quoi je
voulais je voulais faire du bosquet près
normale
cette fois ci sur ty pas faire j'étais
grand je vous l'amènerai pas faire de la
course automobile a été passée de la
voiture était comme un fils étaient
partis y ait autant mettre les pieds ah
ouais c'est en fait je suis parti
m'inscrire quand j'avais 6 ans ouais et
en mi-saison janvier-février mesurer
combien s'y sont déjà fatale ça me fais
pas le malin il est malin comme un vieux
parce que des fois c'est pas vraiment
voilà t'enfoncer pas grand et havas ils
ont donc assis dans tu 20090 manor et
donc ouais et ils m'ont dit de repasser
en septembre puisque les inscriptions
étaient finis en plis prennent pas
encore donné et donc du coup pour que je
fasse du sport
mon père m'a mis à la boxe comme il est
et vous faire via la box et j'ai même
pas c'est ça c'est des histoires que
deux champions nous notre père et nous
amène c'est toujours ouvert à terme il à
faire du ping pong mais c'est vrai
franchement frère c'est bon pas garder
le cami ceinture jaune 2e dan de judo
bat bien sûr mon à sa partie
[Applaudissements]
arrêté j'avais fait arrêter ben on voit
qu'il arrêtait c'est sûr j'ai arrêté
tout bon j'ai maté ce l'émission de ceux
qui crèvent la dalle koh lanta m'amène
away en ce moment ça part dans tous les
sens sur l'île du combat des héros il ya
tellement de stratégie quand javier il
veut te les expliquer il se pose
lui-même ne sait plus qui laissait dire
pour autant tandis ne cherche pas du
tout ce qui m'inquiète aussi les suisses
ils ne cherchent pas c'est qu'elle l'a
et lui il a pas il cherche peut-être
qu'ils cherchent c'est en faisant croire
que qu'il n'a pas alors qu'il l'a moi je
cherche ce qu'ils cherchent
du côté des rouges on a vu que cassandra
flashé sur y est timide à midi je vais
fait chaud ici puis non direction
l'apprennent donnant jusqu'à un coup de
coeur cette aventure
[Musique]
pour moi je vois mon papa
augustine le gars il est tellement
facile sur les épreuves 1 il fait des
siestes pendant que d'autres galèrent ci
ont rien à voir mais grichka bogdanov a
eu une aventure avec jeux populaires
dans con way un enfant que ça on l'a
retrouvée sur les réseaux sociaux
[Musique]
il paraît qu'il prépare une émission d'i
baleineau qui veut gagner des manteaux
des animaux batta ce qu'il habite à
menton j'ai maté le plus grand cabaret
du monde dans les années bonheur
ah ouais ouais ok semerari l'on sait
maintenant sache où je vais si tu pas
encore la bonne ambiance samedi soir
chez patauger fait souvent franck meslin
toujours rien à [ __ ] de ce que ses
invités on va dire notamment marc toesca
le célèbre animateur du top 50 mais en
plus elle a une voix à tomber quoi les
asten fils de malheur et un bonheur
total quoi c'est comment dire je ne sais
pas comment dire patrick mais ces
machines en profitent aussi vu que c'est
encore être en tous lieux ont fait
sauter de cabaret cette année qui
s'éclate eagles en profite
[Applaudissements]
fabien pakistan lecoeuvre aussi était de
la partie pour donner des petites infos
sont au rang des missions et quand ça
passionne pas patrick bas pas de langue
de bois il dit en pleine gueule il a été
il a été régisseur au cinéma après abby
c'est un manuel et je la trompette
depuis l'âge de 8 ans mais qu'est ce que
ça veut s'en fout et vous ne rêvez pas
nouvel enfant de star tout de suite en
pole star on a vu l'enfant de notre
chère isabelle morini bosc et gérard
darmon
je suis content que sean nous et
authentifier ces objets
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est la peur c'est la personne
battant très très bas vient de sonner
bien les malwares sont très belles
personnes préparaient à quoi tu as tu as
fait quoi on gère ici j'ai posé une
caméra dans les toilettes des loges
aujourd'hui dans un petit coup de fil au
losc où il suivait une famille de
cuisiniers on connaissait les to be free
on connaissait trois mousquetaires d'un
nouveau trio cas du cac c'est le game de
la cuisine pas l'origine depuis près
d'un siècle la famille troisgros fait la
fierté de la cuisine française
c'est à vite votre magazine
d'information ils ont subi une nouvelle
brigade de police la brigade anti dab
qu'il course
ceux qui s'attaquent aux distributeurs
de billets forcément quand il absorbait
tu penses à autre chose la chasse au
tiger rock amateur
une équipe de d'abord a été interpellé
mais surtout on a eu droit la meilleure
expression jamais utilisé par un
policier des forces de l'ordre de la
police montée national royal vous voulez
comme un malade avec une voiture qui a
déjà même pas immatriculé comme il faut
et une ferveur je joue avec mes couilles
mais pas si pendrel chez soi et on
arrive déjà à la fin de la chronique se
les partager des petits compliment c'est
le moment jalade mac de la santé le seul
mag ou cyril ne prendra jamais un
chroniqueur d'encadrement la i30 j'aime
beaucoup aujourd'hui dans le mac de la
santé on parle d'huile d'arachide ça et
c'est important dans la cuisine sauf que
pour michel cymes visiblement ils
pensent ça vient d'ailleurs c'est mieux
que non mais moi quand j'ai dit que
c'est miss donc c'est mieux que l'huile
ont fait des fritures avec de l'huile
quoi de rachid en général rachid
sinon dans le mac de la santé oms deux
journalistes une affiche pas un peu du
résultat quand tu les envoies ensemble
faire un sujet est bon se retrouvent
après la diffusion de graisses
alimentaires le retour en grâce pour ce
documentaire signé claire ricker maxime
soûlard et olivier lapointe et enfin ce
week-end c'est leur saute 50 minutes
inside et comme promis cyril on s'amuse
à changer les images aborder les vraies
voix off et ça fonctionne
j'adore ça
britney spears
après quatre ans de résidence à las
vegas qui m'ont permis de se refaire une
image
la chanteuse de 36 ans prend un nouveau
départ le retour des tuche après monaco
et l'amérique ils s'attaquent à l'elysée
nous avons suivi l'équipe du film en
plein marathon
rihanna va-t-elle s'installer à paris la
chanteuse semble vouloir s'établir dans
la capitale george clooney va-t-il
mettre un terme à sa carrière d'acteur
la star dit vouloir se consacrer à la
réalisation
alors que certains lui prédisent un
avenir en politique
bonsoir à tous
[Applaudissements]